scientists have looked long and hard
into the origins of Earth's water and
what they found is amazing our planet
shouldn't be wet at all the place where
the earth is right now seems very dry so
if the earth formed as a dry Rock around
a hot young star then how did this water
get here every possibility has problems
and we want to know the answer
tracing the exact source of Earth's
water is surprisingly complex
the journey starts over 4.6 billion
years ago during the formation of our
solar system
a vast cloud of gas and dust hangs in
space inside this cloud atoms of
hydrogen and oxygen proliferate
oxygen is one of the most abundant atoms
in the universe hydrogen is the most
abundant atom in the universe you're
gonna get a lot of whatever it is they
form over millions of years these highly
reactive atoms bind together to form h2o
water water is a fairly simple molecule
it's made of two hydrogen's and one
oxygen
this newly-formed water sticks to dust
grains inside the gas cloud slowly
building up into crystals of ice
eventually the icy dusty cloud becomes
so dense it starts to collapse under
gravity
this begins the process that forms our
solar system there's enough water here
to fill the Earth's oceans three million
times over when we see stars that are
forming right now and we study hundreds
thousands of them we see disks of
material beginning to orbit around the
young stars gas dust and there's
certainly quite a bit of water in that
material gravity pulls more and more
material into the center of the cloud
raising pressure and temperature
eventually the extreme forces spark
fusion and a protostar our infant son
births into life
bad news for the water surrounding the
newly born star the environment of a
star when it forms this incredibly hot
and violent any water that was existing
in that region because water's a
volatile material would be destroyed
water cannot exist near a star early on
during its formation